so ist das vielen dank lars klingbeil
ist bei uns erklären wir was können sie
einschätzen beim jetzigen stand der
dinge was wie würden sie den jetzigen
stand der dinge bewerten die spd es
zurück so das ist das klare signal des
heutigen abends wir waren vor ein paar
wochen abgeschlagen auf platz drei wir
hatten 13 14 15 prozentpunkte und jetzt
stehen wir auf eins und das ist etwas wo
wir uns darüber freuen dass die
wählerinnen und wähler uns das vertrauen
schenken das 400.000 spd-mitglieder
gekämpft haben in den letzten wochen
darüber bin ich sehr glücklich dass mit
dem platz eins ist im moment noch eine
etwas gewagte these denn wir haben wenn
man es mal im fußball vergleichen
betrachten noch nicht mal halbzeit ja
aber wir sehen ja dass der rote balken
hoch geht und dass der schwarze balken
sehr weit runter geht also der auftrag
an olaf scholz eine regierung zu bilden
der ist ja eindeutig da die menschen
wollen dass olaf scholz der nächste
kanzler dieses landes ist aber wir haben
noch nicht mal eine hochrechnung um
diese uhrzeit sondern wir haben
prognosen das heißt es ist noch nicht
eine einzige briefwähler stimme
wahrscheinlich eingeflossen in die
zahlen die wir da gesehen habe insofern
ist ihre these jetzt vielleicht auch ein
bisschen kühl also wir freuen uns über
den rückhalt den wir haben wir sehen die
spd war vor ein paar wochen noch auf
platz drei jetzt sind wir vorne das
zeigen haben das zeigen die ersten
zahlen jetzt veröffentlicht wurden und
jetzt warten wir mal den rest des abends
aber ich bin sehr optimistisch dass es
klappt wie waren denn die bewertungen
sind vorstand und dem präsidium gegeben
hat zwischen 17 und 18 uhr der lage
diese zahlen ja durchaus auch schon vor
tagen ähnliche zahlen vor wir haben uns
gefreut halle haben sich bei olaf scholz
bedankt deren fulminanten wahlkampf
geführt hatte hat die partei gezogen in
den letzten wochen 400.000 mitglieder
die mit ihm unterwegs waren wir haben
gesehen die plätze waren voll das
interesse an der sozialdemokratie war da
also wir haben uns gefreut wir waren
dankbar und jetzt warten wir mal den
abend ab das ist ein knappes rennen das
haben wir immer gesagt aber ich bin mir
sicher am ende liegt die spd vorne weil
sie die prognosezahlen ebenso gefeiert
haben was würden sie denn mit diesen
prognosezahlen für eine regierung
veranstalten wollen ich sage immer
schärfer heute wird ein bisschen
gefeiert wir freuen uns über das
comeback der spd und morgen werden in
den gremien beraten wie es weiter geht
formuliert es anders welche
welche koalitions möglichkeiten würden
sie den unter den gegebenen bedingungen
sofern sie sich verfestigen überhaupt
für denkbar halten sie haben wir darauf
hingewiesen wir müssen den haaren
abwarten die wissen noch gar nicht
welche koalition möglich sind aber heute
haben wird gefeiert morgen wird geguckt
wie wir eine stabile regierung zusammen
kriegen wir sehen uns morgen früh wieder
vielen dank für die im moment gebt
zurück ins studio